salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor et
non on commence pas par la fin on est
arrivé sur un spot qui avait déjà été
fait visiblement par des très bons
pêcheurs alléments félicitations à tous
bon par contre il aurait dû ramasser la
ferraille ouais mais c'est dur à
ramasser peut-être qu'ils ont laissé le
temps et qu'ils viendront après on va
pas critiquer parce que c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui on n'est pas tout seul on
est avec Wim qui est encore là et avec
Danny encore une fois tous les réseaux
de Wim sont en description mais vous
commencez à le connaître ça fait un
moment qu'on pêche avec lui et regardez
c'est encore plein de d'objets donc là
on a Dan qui nous a fait du du happy
gas et bien s est en compagnie de Rasta
ce qu'on va faireon va attaquer la pêche
tout de
suite c'est pas
moi ça va ça va ça
va
si
si tu veux que ça
filme bien
joué ça aussi ça vient un
scooter
bien joué allez voyons ce qui reste dans
ce
canal ouais partage j'ai quelque
chose
ohé
ouais
téléphoneéléphone ouais
dopone logic oh non est déjà
sale ils ont pensé à
l'environnement allez petit vélo
hop ça se
bloque ça vient c'est lourd
vas-y moto une moto
est il est
joli ok
co il y a aussi un
vélo non ramasse qu'on peut belle
trouvaille on va au faireilleur regarde
les
vidéos
là-bas pas de l'argent c'est là-bas
truc l'autre l'autre passerelle ou
là-bas à
[Musique]
droite cool c'est joli hein sympa
ouais tu pense sonent au revoir ok ben
sympa la
Yamaha allez un scooter de plus ah le
c'est pas
mal
ok
iron plasti non non not plastic mal
aluminium ptt00 allez PTT 3800
abonnez-vous et là j'ai quelque chose
gag000 abonn une mition ah oui calibre
12 vide et ça
surtout une boîte de filtre on va
l'ouvrir quand même
ouais un bout de
radiateur c'est quoi TR
plastique l'autre surment non
ok une autre protoxyde
d'azote alors Quentin on veut trouver
quoi aujourd'hui des
AR bij des coffres
for ça va je répond ce
soir parfz on a quelque chose
vé vé et ça c'éit ça quea
ditour bien joué encore du
protxide
filtr ok des ch
oh moneyx money box là j'ai une caisse
elle est
fermée on
l'ouvre allez
ah il a une
pièce une pièce ah çax
ok
ti
ah ok
non ok good
begin une
caisse ah non c'est bon j'ai peur non
c'est pas
l'échelle OK
gun il y avait un pistolet gun
[Musique]
ok
oh oh j'ai vu un
pistoleter
chercheristolet
alleztin tu dois le retrouver ouais je
dois le retrouver
ok non
[Musique]
OK
cool bien jou bon début
qutin mini
gap mini
gap cool
oh
Not
[Applaudissements]
merci donc c'est bien un pistolet
d'alarme on le voit parce que là c'est
pas du métal c'est du zarmac du zarmac
donc mais
sympa
ouais oh
joli il y a une
boîte je
touchearen
OK
est joli ouaisa arrête de faire la
star oh ciseau des ciseau ouais bien
joué
nones là fonctionne
ouais ciseau
mapède allez oh un téléphone en a fait
au moins TR aujourd'hui déjà ouais mais
il retombe à chaque fois attends fa j'
aille doucement
o je finir par me
bloquer ok pignon de vélo
j'ai enfin trouvé ma première arme en
compagnie des Hollandais parce qu'à
chaque fois c'est qui trouv tout donc je
suis content çaers c'est vrai vra chose
qui
d'arriver derrière toi c'est incroyable
et ça continue oh une
batterie une batterie scooter non tu
crois il a un TR brillant brillant là oh
ouais c'est une boucle d'oreill ok mais
faut garder hein ah s pas de couleur
mais c'est un peu il y a que l'anneau
qui a attrapé ouais c'est pas aimenté en
tout cas
plus et ça c'est un transp ou il en a
encore des bijoux oh c'est plein de
bijou
ok des
dédicacé
ouais un
autoradio sympa et aussi un l'URE de
pêche allez oh non il y avait encore un
téléphone il est là au bord ah ouais je
vais essayer de le rechoper ouais belle
plaquette une clé aussi tiens elle est
encore très bien
ouais allez on va essayer de sortir le
téléphone il est très peuenté on dirait
ah bah il est retombé
on retrouvera peut-être après ah non il
est là j' même pas fait
gaffe by SFR ok allez tiens je te
l'offre merci c'est pas très lourd oh
non protxy
d'AZ
ok je crois que c'est un porte-monnaie
ça il me
semble regarde non avec une en chaîne ou
c'est possible c'est possible dites-moi
au commentaire mais je suis pas sûr ouis
vide
écrasé un gros l de
[Musique]
maritime
une
selle on va essayer de
làbaser
làb quand fait une bêtise il s accroché
sur
l'échelle
alletin il a fait une bêtise donc
maintenant il doit décoincer son
aimant bien ça va il a des
choses sur Réau
merci un abonné attends faut que
j'enlève mon
aim attends
ouais un
autoradio
encore blo quelle idée de laisser ta
corde là aussi jusqu'au
fond
non c'est pas
normal bon je vais tenter 1 2 ouais
c'est bon c'est bon bien joué
allez je crois qu'on a une
touche oh une ép
non
j'ai dommage ok dommage la
poussette la poussette
de ok
cool c'est la corde de Quentin qui était
coincée on va voir si ça lui a permis de
pêcher quelque chose quand même à part
le le fameux tuyau qui nous gêne depuis
le début que je vais finir par réussir à
sortir voilà ce que tu as attrapé
Quentin c'était vraiment pas une belle
pêche tout ça pour ça
ouais faut que tu répares tes deux
cordes ou moi je vais continuer à pêcher
avec le mien on va essayer de tirer un
peu loin magnet
lildx
lex alors qu'est-ce que j'ai ah ouiure
de pêche tiens pour notre am
pêcheur il est un peu abîmé mais bon
mais on peut toujours l'utiliser ouais
je
pense une sorte de filtre à gasoil
vélo ok quelque chose
d'aut
faut c'est un scanner
ouais ou c'est
cool cool
une boucle d'oreill
elle brille
bien
ok encore un
vélo il se croit Amsterdam là ça y
est allez on va continuer encore
un voilà je me suis décalé je suis
toujours sous la passerelle on va voir
ce qu'on
trouve faut faut que tu
viennes il y a un endroit où on peut
être deux il
full j'ai un gros
truc là c'est rempli les gars
là j'ai encore un gros
truc alors qu'est-ce que j'ai
encore
h de la fonte mais il y a plein de trucs
hein en vrai bof alors là c'est Prieux
alors je vais m'attacher à ce truc en
fer pour pêcher ici ici on a plus de
chance qu'il a des choses parce que
c'est tellement inaccessible que ça a dû
pas être fait beaucoup ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va faire une boucle là ok on
a quelque
chose
waouh
twist
twister
gaufrette
cigarette encore quelque chose de gros
ça vient un vélo ça non et oui vélo ah
il est pas très vieux celui-là
ok coolonnez
dédicace aux
abonnésonnezv je vous
mettrai moi je
vas-y et à moi et à
Med OK
vous monsieur je vous a ah merci merci
j'ai quelque chose d'hyper
lourd ça lâché
waouh ça c'est du c'est une bouteille de
gaz décrocher de l'ment
sans la faire tomber dans l'eau de
nouveau de
trésas besoin d'aide j'arrive
ouais qu'est-ce qu'on
a des gros plots là des télées ouais il
y en a plein
ouais fait chier ça
ouais c'est les poteau qu' a dans la
route
[__] comment tu fais pour l'enlever du
coup comment on l'enlèveett làhaut au
milieu attends
salut à
YouTube
salut
abonnez-vous c'est le bordel c'est la
sortie du collège
[Musique]
ok un ressort pas mal de trucs
un téléphone
ok
Protx fait mal ça fait
mal plus dro a plus de place ou euh
c'est votre enfant bof lui mais pas du
tout si on l'a
adopté non c'est pas
vrai prend votre chien comment ça
comment le prendre non on garde il est
croisé à quille
nu
Mons
merci c'est trop
lourd j'arrive
ok un
panneau il y a pas de
panneau
rien un lamp
àair c'est une lampe
alogène ah un vélo pour changer ah oui
un
vélo attention
OK
B un panneau un panneau eté
TR fais tomber ton téléphone on le
repêche
vasysieur je garantis rien ou vas-y ok
peut-être que j'ai un bout
ah the bike le vélo
OK
ouais tu peux faire des roues arrières
tranquille ok super canon
ball pétanque B une boule de pétanque
voilà donc le résultat de cette pêche
àément bien sûr en rajoutant nos
découvertes à celles qui ont déjà été
faites par une équipe qui est passée ici
précédemment c'est totalement n'importe
quoi en sachant surtout qu'il en reste
et qu'on a fait qu'un seul côté du P
aujourd'hui go ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va ramener le maximum mais bon on
est venu à 5 donc on a pas énormément de
place dans le camionous non rest pas en
dessous aujourd'hui on récupère donc le
maximum qu'on peut et dans tous les cas
il y aura assurément une partie de à cet
endroit tellement c'est
dingue
beauful on est certain qu'on est passé à
côté de dizaines d'objets intéressants
aujourd'hui si c'est pas déjà le cas
pensez à vous abonner pour être averti
lorsque la partie 2 sera publiée à cet
endroit
portez-vous bien et on se dit à la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo de
pêche cool
bravo